kollektive ekstase kunden das bad in der
unsterblichkeit das größte religiöse
fest der hindus das größte der welt
dieses mal kürzer und kleiner
schließlich herrscht corona statt 100
millionen besucher sind es vielleicht
nur zehn nur zehn millionen also alles
etwas knapper dabei seien einmal im
leben wenigstens es drängt viele und
viele drängen sich hat und seine gruppe
kommen aus bihar haben 24 stunden in der
bahn gesessen auf den letzten kilometern
fährt ein bus ist 69 die meisten hier
sind nicht mehr jung aber jede strapaze
lohnt sich für einen gläubigen hinter
das ist der platz der götter wer hierher
kommt der wird rein
ich bin zum ersten mal auf der computer
in haridwar der allmächtige ist hier
allgegenwärtig
als awad sein ticket vor wochen gebucht
hat sheen corona in indien unter
kontrolle
jetzt sind die zahlen katastrophal mehr
als 250.000 neue infektionen jeden tag
aber zur reisegruppe wird zwar getestet
doch nur lückenhaft sind die kontrollen
vertrauen ist besser für mich ist klar
der glaube besinnt corona und die
regierung hat alle vorkehrungen
getroffen
jetzt haben sie uns noch einmal getestet
negativ und nun können wir beruhigt die
kinder feiern
jeder weiß dass es ein ansteckungsrisiko
gibt aber es ist nun mal die reise ihres
lebens für jeden in der gruppe mein mann
ist als das gehen fällt ihm schwer
aber wir wollten unbedingt an diesen
heiligen platz
unsere söhne wollten nicht dass wir hier
fahren
sie machen sich sorgen aber dieser
pilgerreise ist richtig wer weiß wann
gott uns zu sich ruft vielleicht schon
bald aber muss seinen negativen test
vorzeigen vielleicht ja weil unsere
kamera läuft der test ist jedenfalls die
eintrittskarte ins zeltlager
die reise war hart und morgen kommt der
höhepunkt das bad im heiligen fluss
etwas ausruhen kann jetzt nicht schaden
entspannung geht auch anders auf der
kola
es liegt was in der luft beim aufmarsch
der stars der heiligen männern im
hinduismus werden sie verehrt als
suchende als wissende viele sind asketen
haben dem weltlichen leben völlig
entsagt und auf irdische fragen haben
sie eigene antworten
jeden morgen machen wir einen speziellen
sirup der uns vor corona schützt die
ecke kommt rein kardamom pfeffer blätter
vom neben baum und noch ein paar
kräutern
so bekommst du keinen husten und kein
chor und auch gewinnt hat sich dem
glauben verschrieben das ist den jüngst
besonders gut gelungen und selbst das
hat etwas mit corona zu tun als zu
beginn der pandemie vor einem jahr der
große locker und verhängt hatte blieb
ich in meinem ashram und meditierte mir
gefiel das gut ich hatte noch nie so
viel zeit und muße zum meditieren
gewinnt verteilt masken und
desinfektionsmittel er ist keiner der
korona leugnet vorsicht können nicht
schaden angst jedoch müsse nicht sein
sagt mir was soll hier passieren wenn
wir uns an die regeln halten
wie soll corona hierher kommt das wasser
des heiligen gang es ist mächtig keiner
unserer heiligen männer die darin baden
system als kranke war leider doch
dutzende autos wurden positiv getestet
mindestens zwei sind inzwischen
gestorben und wer weiß wie hoch die
dunkelziffer ist in dieser unheiligen
bilanz das virus macht vor dem glauben
nicht halt
aus der luft regnet es rote rosenblätter
das ist immer so auf den punkt dass es
am boden desinfektionsmittel regnet ist
neu die pandemie ausgerechnet hier
ausgerechnet jetzt zu bekämpfen es wirkt
ein bisschen hilflos vorschriften für
heilige männer die auf dem weg sind ein
bad der unsterblichkeit zunehmend
schwierig ganz schwierig
[Musik]
masten abstand hygiene sind jetzt und
hier wörter von einem anderen planeten
ein pures spaßbad
wo wind ist mittendrin
es ist wunderbar großartig
ich bin glücklich alle heiligen männer
sind glücklich jeder ist glücklich
ein stück flussabwärts erfüllen sich die
normalsterblichen ihren traum im
getümmel auch die pilgergruppe aus bhs
ist der moment den avant und seine frau
herbeigesehnt haben der moment der sich
von sünden reinwäscht und der moment der
ihnen erkenntnis schenkt corona ist eine
strafe für das was gegen die natur gegen
das göttliche geschieht vollbringen wir
gutes sonst müssen wir leihen
er bete dass jeder mensch das erkenne
sagt awad denn nur dann könne jeder
erreichen wonach doch alle streben
gesundheit glückseligkeit